hey guys I'm writing right hey guys
Sally's here again people have been like
where's Sally been and she's been doing
stuff right stuff yeah no no well let's
just say it involves some kinky [ __ ]
she's going to school
we're gonna watch shrek is love shrek is
life part 3 I love this French I think
it's brilliant I saw the first one with
you which was awesome that was word and
then Sangam wasn't as disturbing was
still pretty bad
no way it was just a little more out
there but it definitely wasn't as creepy
definitely not no but this one Trek
would exploding you you imagine having
sex with shrek for a second imagine
shrek is in one hole and donkeys in the
other huh yeah huge like [ __ ] two
black guys donkeys don't have that bit
no I'm thinking of horses yeah you think
you lose yeah what Sally knows dick
sizes we're duo donkeys don't happy that
20 cuz the ass you know the donkey would
be in the end yes yes as we come here
for witty jokes
[Music]
I was 13 years old it was the first day
of high school and it was very nervous I
found my locker after the orientation I
began to walk quickly to the nearest
restroom
but notice that I'm being followed by
the older trick students what seems as
though he says as he walks towards me I
feel very intimidated shrink please
[Music]
Shrek 3 [ __ ] kid jerk number two
asks me suddenly the scent of
the boys are unaware of the SH reckoning
that is about to burn shrek is drek kid
I would [ __ ] destroy the entire yeah
he's no right babble like that's it
we're going to happen the door bursts
open end it it's Shrek bursts don't
physically
ecologies shrekt penis smash all stars
turned up dual living the force of the
music is so strong that it shreds the
skin of all of the trick bully's faces
straight off shirt grabs all the three
of them and mashes them together into
one big ball taking on the shape of
large he tells us the trick ball out of
the window is the screaming of students
can be heard from the outside Shrek
turns and
I just can't resist anymore I can't
believe them down I collapse on my hands
and knees offering myself to this hurt
tears my mouth open as shrek in zelda
mighty ogre and fills me to the brim
with his pungent onion love my eyes are
filled with tears tears of joy tears of
by waking in the intensive care unit
covered in copious amounts of onion
juice and went on to graduate high sun
and receive a scholarship for a
prestigious university
thank you shirt shrek is love shrek is
life
[Music]
brilliant absolutely brilliant comedy
has never been this good until now by
your reaction I can tell you're on the
same page right now um that seemed a
little more serious and then when I got
into the Shrek part those two those way
too much those we too much thrusting and
then the guy come it's like no I don't
like the suicide thing I hate the
suicide thing this is not okay
what what um makes it more disturbing is
the fact that the computer effects got a
lot better
hey yo man [ __ ] this looks kind of more
read looks a little bit scarier and more
defined I think it would be better when
we get to the day and age where we can
see Shrek actually pulled down his pants
see his penis and then you know see some
real homosexual sex happening between
ogre and men and like I said donkey she
get involved they should enemy you into
there that would be cool let's get a
petition going for that [ __ ] Sally I'm
telling you right now
I missed you I really missed you I
haven't seen you in forever
and mr. boobs I tried doing a sincere a
miss you moment and then what happens
what happens was trying to make out with
you tonight's not that night no but most
nights it is me if I smell like I yeah
do you know I smell me why just smell
like onions cuz I ain't Mediterranean
food today Oh
anyway guys if you're new to the channel
you can subscribe here for real rejects
and you can subscribe subscribe
subscribe to Sally's channel which
apparently the buttons right in front of
her face yeah there we go
subscribe to Sally's channel cuz I'm
working on a cool short film it's
spider-man
with me as MJ what I don't know after
watching this me just react to shrek
porn I don't know if people will be into
that but there's gonna be more shrek
porn I'm pretty sure after this there's
gonna be a crap ton of shark porn on
porn websites now crap so at this point
in the video I would like to give shout
outs Andrew Coleman he said a lot of
[ __ ] but in one of those parts he said
he wants a shout-out Andrew Coleman you
could totally have a shout-out my friend
hmm
don't get it the Gary Coleman girl wait
that was on Drake and Josh I don't think
that's a real thing George Foreman girls
a real thing oh yeah Gary Coleman girl
well you just assign yourself dirty head
your shoutout sorry I'm supposed to be a
perfect shout out for Andrew and you if
you like Drake and Josh this this will
be okay but nothing it's just got really
awkward okay wait is this real or are we
filming either way it's good for camera
Raymond mock Louis dick Oh Raymond mock
you wanted to shout out not gonna say
what you said before but you're kind of
a dick I'm just letting you know a
little bit of a dick yeah your potatoes
that is like the worst thing to me who
wants to be up a date with things of
carbs like unless your fries yeah sure
no fry your potatoes their potato
hmm what's gonna happen brush moon the
yeah Raymond you can still have a
shout-out I guess it'd be nicer to
Veronica yeah she has the best I don't
want to say what she has the best but
she's she's good you know I mean how
would I know right
[Laughter]
no no I wish just just imagine yeah I'm
trying to law of attraction sorry I
think your secret yeah if I keep
masturbating to Veronica I might get
hurt one day I'm exactly did not work
with you but it's gonna work with
Veronica yeah
wheats uh pizza please can I have a
shout-out
we saw visa of course you can have a
shout-out okay yeah busted me I wasn't
that bad you say Busta beat and she
instead wraps I was if I wanted you a
beat but that was way more reward time I
hear the word beat got a rap got it
connected Louise the pizza you got a
little rap shout-out from Sally never
happened before first time ever on this
channel Sally gave a rap shout-out yes
shout out complete